[APPLAUSE]
RICHARD SUSSKIND:
Thank you very much,
and thank you,
Google, for inviting
us to talk about our book about
the future of the professions,
which really focuses on
the impact of technology
and how we share
expertise in society.
And Daniel and I will be
doing a double act today.
I'll be talking after Daniel
about trends in technology
and the evolution of
professional service
and artificial intelligence.
Before that, though, Daniel
will be setting the scene,
discussing what we regard as
the two possible futures that
are panning out for
the professions,
and he'll also give
you a flavor of what's
happening in the vanguard
of the professions today.
After I complete my
words on AI, Daniel
will then speak about jobs
and the future of jobs.
I'll come back and
speak about expertise
and a couple of moral issues
that arise from our book.
So we will speak to you
for about half an hour,
maybe 40 minutes.
And we'll cover these main
topics as snappily as we can.
Thank you.
DANIEL SUSSKIND: So we're often
asked why we wrote the book.
What can I say about a
co-author who, in many ways,
has become like a father to me.
My dad's been
working in the field
of artificial intelligence and
the law for the past 35 years,
looking at how it all
transforms the legal profession.
And what he's found is
that in talking, generally,
to audiences of lawyers,
at the end, a stray doctor,
a stray accountant, a
stray teacher will come up
and say, that's very interesting
in the legal profession,
but what you're talking
about could apply very well
in our profession as well.
So we were first chatting about
this about five years ago.
I was working in a policy
unit at Downing Street
at the time, tax policy, health
policy, education policy,
and I had a good overview of
lots of different professions.
And it was clear that
significant change was
in the air, and that these
different professions seemed
to be facing a common
set of challenges.
So we had the idea
of investigating
the professions more generally.
And we set out on a journey
together to do exactly that,
and the result was this book.
So our research-- we looked
at eight professions-- health,
education, law, journalism,
divinity, management,
consulting, tax and
audit, and architecture.
But the thinking applies to more
than just those professions.
It's about the
professions in general.
We have about 100
interviews we draw on,
800, more than 100 sources.
And the picture that we
get is a radical change,
and our book is trying
to make sense of that.
[INAUDIBLE] my dad
said before, we
see two futures for
the professions.
And the first one is
reassuringly familiar.
Professionals continue
to work as they
have done since the middle
of the 19th century,
but they use these
new technologies
to streamline and optimize the
traditional way in which they
worked.
So there's lots of examples
of this-- doctors using Skype
to talk to patients, architects
using computer-assisted design
technology to build
more complicated,
bigger buildings, teachers
using online resources to help
in the classroom.
But the second future's a
very different proposition.
It involves a
transformation in the way
that the expertise
of professionals
is made available.
And what we call
increasingly capable
systems and machines will not
only streamline and optimize
the traditional ways in
which professions work,
but it will actively
displace work
in traditional professions.
And for now, we see these two
futures developing in parallel,
but in the long
run, we anticipate
that that second
future will dominate.
We'll find new and better ways
to share expertise in society,
and that will lead to
a gradual dismantling
of the traditional professions.
And that's broadly where
the latest evidence
and our thinking leads us.
But our research
also led us to ask
a more fundamental
question, which is why do we
have the professions at all?
And our answer, and it
runs through all the work
that we've done is,
that in analogous ways,
the professions are a solution
to the same problem, which
is that none of us have
sufficient expertise
to cope with all the
daily challenges in life.
No one can know everything.
Human beings, the
term we use for this,
they have limited understanding.
And so they turn to
doctors, lawyers, teachers,
who have the knowledge
that they don't to get on.
In what we call a
brick-based society,
the professions, as
I said, are the way
that we solve these
daily challenges.
They have knowledge, experience,
skills, and know-how.
And the term we use for
this is practical expertise.
They've got the
practical expertise
but that those they help do not.
They operate under
a grand bargain,
which is an arrangement that
gives the professions the right
to provide certain
services, often
to the exclusion of others.
And they act as gatekeepers.
They're asked to
look offer, to curate
their own respective
bodies of knowledge.
The doctors look after
medical knowledge.
Lawyers look after legal
knowledge, and so on.
So that's our analysis
of the professions
in a brick-based society.
But we're no longer in
a brick-based society.
We're in what we call a
technology-based internet
society, and our
professions are creaking.
They're unaffordable.
Most people, most
organizations, can't
afford the advice of
first-rate professionals,
or indeed, any professionals.
They're antiquated.
They rely upon old techniques
for producing and sharing
knowledge and information.
They're opaque.
And sometimes, this is because
the work the professionals do
is genuinely too complex for
lay people to understand,
but other times,
lots of ways there's
intentional obfuscation,
and they underperform.
Given the way the
professionals are organized,
the work and experience
of the very best
can only ever be enjoyed by
a privileged and lucky few.
And the expertise of the very
best is a very finite resource.
And so we should
ask the question,
as we move from this
brick-based industrial society
to an internet
society, might there
be entirely new ways of
organizing professional work,
ways that are more
affordable, more accessible
than the traditional approach?
Might we be able to make some
of this practical expertise
available online?
Do we still need
these old gatekeepers?
And to help us think
through these issues,
we decided to find out what
was going on at the vanguard.
So we spoke to the thinkers
and leading practitioners.
And I want to now just give
a flavor of what we found.
So in education, more people
signed up in a single year
to Harvard's online
courses than had
attended Harvard in its
entire 377 year existence
up to that point.
Khan Academy, online collection
of instructional videos,
practice problems.
It's great stuff.
I use it to teach some
of my students maths.
It has 10 million
unique users each month.
That's, in a way, a higher
effective attendance
than the entire school
population in England.
In medicine, 190 million people,
not all of them hypochondriacs,
visit WebMD, which is an online
network of help websites.
190 million visits is more
than the number of visits
to all the traditional
doctors working in the US.
Similarly, the US
Food and Drug Agency
said, by 2018, there will be
at least 1.5 billion people
in the world with at
least one medical app
on their smartphone.
In journalism, on
its sixth birthday,
the Huffington Post had
more unique visitors
than the New York Times,
which was 164 years old.
Bleacher Report, an online
blog written by 2,000 people,
now has 22 million
unique users each month,
enough to rival CNN Sports.
Associated Press
last year started
to use algorithms to
computerize the production
of their earnings reports.
And when they did
that, they were
going to produce
15 times as many
as they could when they relied
upon professional financial
journalists [INAUDIBLE].
In the legal world,
every year on eBay
there are 60 million
disputes that
arise and are resolved online
without lawyers using what's
called an e-mediation platform.
Bear in mind, again, 60
million is 40 times as many
as the number of
civil cases that
are launched in the entire
English or Welsh justice
system.
Again, the legal world, the
best recognized legal brand
in the US isn't a
traditional law firm,
it's Legalzoom.com, an online
provider of legal advice
and automated document
drafting service.
In tax, last year in
America, 48 million Americans
used online tax preparation
software rather than
a traditional tax accountant.
And here, HMRC, they've
got a fraud detection
system called Connect.
It sifts through each time
about 1 billion pieces of data,
and it's said that's
more data than is
held in the British Library.
No mean feat, given the fact
that the British Library
has a copy of every
single book that's
ever been published in the UK.
In architecture,
a few years ago,
a firm, Gramazio and
Kohler, used a swarm
of autonomous flying
robots, pictured
there, to build a structure
out of 1,500 bricks.
And a Dutch architecture
firm, DUS Architects,
has begun to print and
assemble a house made entirely
of printed parts,
using a printer that
can print objects that are
three and half meters tall.
In consulting, Accenture,
a consulting firm,
no longer employees
just consultants.
It has 750 hospital
nurses on staff.
And Deloitte, which was founded
170 years ago as an audit
practice, now has
200,000 professionals,
and its own full scale
university set in a 700,000
square foot campus in Texas.
So in Second Life,
the online world where
half a million people
control their own avatars,
there's a group of Christians.
And on an island, a virtual
island called Epiphany,
they've built a
slightly gloomy-looking
Anglican cathedral.
It offers daily services,
a weekly Bible study class,
and counseling services.
And again in religion, 2011,
amidst some controversy,
the Vatican granted
the first imprimatur
to this app called Confession.
An imprimatur is
the official license
that the Catholic Church
gives to religious texts.
So they gave it to
this app, which helps
you prepare for confession.
And it's got tools
for tracking sin,
and dropdown panels and
options for contrition.
And the controversy was
that the Vatican said
that this will help you
prepare for confession,
but it won't replace confession.
And there was an argument
about that with a local church.
So we believe that
all these developments
across the professions
are related.
They reflect a transformation
in the professions,
and that's what we've
been studying together
for the past five years.
Thank you.
RICHARD SUSSKIND:
Thank you, Dan.
So when we looked
across the professions,
looked at the evidence that
Daniel has discussed with you,
and much else besides, we
identified eight patterns
and 30 trends that we found
across the professions.
And I'm not going to
delve into each one today.
That's a chapter at
the end of the book.
But I wanted to
just choose three
to give you a
flavor of the trend
level of what's happening.
Above all else, I suspect
we're seeing a move away
from what we called bespoke
handling of professional work.
So this is professionals
acting as craftspeople,
with each case, or problem,
or patient, or client
having unique
circumstances, and starting
with a blank sheet of paper
and fashioning a solution
with a handcrafting method.
We're seeing a move
away from that.
We're seeing what we call
decomposition, a breaking down
of often very complex
professional work
into component parts, and
finding the most efficient way
to do each part of work.
This is a new division of labor
across professional services.
And what we're also
seeing as part of this
is, that many of the components,
once you start breaking down
professional work, although
the whole looks complicated,
many of the some parts
in medicine, in law,
in tax and audit, right across
the professional services
market, many of the subparts
actually can be routinized.
And here's where we
can get great savings,
and here's where we can
actually use technology
in new and imaginative ways.
So we've discuss at length
each of these trends
and many others.
And we're not saying
all professions are
going at the same
pace, but we are
saying there's a
common set of patterns
visible across the professions.
And technology is
clearly underpinning
much of the change.
Now, we're not here to
lecture Google on technology.
We just wanted to make a
couple of observations.
First of all, in
1996, I wrote a book
called "The Future of Law."
And this was about the
impact of technology
on lawyers and the courts.
And in that book-- and this
will seem remarkable now-- one
of my themes was
that the dominant way
that lawyers and
clients would come
to communicate in the
future would be by email.
Now, I joke not.
The Law Society of
England, they all
said I shouldn't be
allowed to speak in public.
They said I was bringing the
profession into disrepute
by suggesting that clients
and lawyers would use email
with one another,
and that I didn't
understand confidentiality, that
I didn't understand security.
Please don't take for
granted in the professions
that people will
embrace technology
very rapidly We have a very
resistant group of users.
The way we make
sense of technology--
and I'm half a technologist
and half a lawyer-- we
organize our thinking about
technology under four headings.
We identify, as so
many other people
do, an exponential or at
least explosive growth
in the underpinning
technologies, processing power,
bandwidth, data
storage capacity.
We also talk-- and
Daniel's used this phrase
before-- a lot of
increasingly capable machines.
More of which [INAUDIBLE].
Our assisting machines are
becoming increasingly capable.
The point again,
as so many others
have done, the fact that
our devices are becoming
increasingly pervasive,
and that circuitry is also
being embedded in objects around
us, and indeed in human beings.
And finally, in making
sense of the American world
of technology, we talk about the
ways in which human beings are
increasingly connected.
Just to focus on that one
question of increasing
capability, to unpack that
a little, what interests us
is the progress being
made recently on big data,
on data analytics, and the way
in which large bodies of data
can yield fascinating and
interesting insights, patterns,
correlations.
We're interested in the
development of search,
as well as Watson type
technologies, where certain
question and answer
scenarios, you actually
have systems solving problems.
We're also fascinated
by effective computing.
I'll say more on
that in a second.
And of course robotics.
Effective computing,
this is less known,
even amongst technologists.
This is devoted to the ways in
which machines, systems, can
both detect and
express human emotions.
The notion that a machine
can look at one's face
and tell whether or not
you're angry, or surprised,
or disgusted, the idea now
that machines, more accurately
than human beings, can
tell whether or not a smile
is fake smile or
a genuine small.
So this growing
body of evidence,
this growing investment
in a whole bundle
of technologies, very
crudely improving greatly
in user interface,
but allowing machines
not just to behave inertly,
but actually, as I say,
both express and detect,
determine the emotions
of their users.
And the final elements of
the big four at the top
was that our machines are
increasingly connected.
And of course, one
can speak endlessly
about social networking, but
just focusing specifically
on the professions, we're
finding within professions
there are closed social
networks in medicine, in law,
in education, in architecture.
We're also finding-- and a
classic example of patients
like me-- the opportunity
for what we call communities
of experience, where
people who have
been the recipients of
professional service
can come along and share their
experience in law, in medicine,
in religion, in general
problem solving,
in tax, and in
architecture as well.
And then, of course, the whole
notion of crowd sourcing.
And we're seeing
in architecture,
in medicine, in business
problems generally,
new ways of reaching
out to large communities
of individuals who can
contribute to problem solving.
This is radical stuff in
the world of professions.
We classically think of lawyers,
and doctors, and auditors,
and counselors, one-to-one
professional advice,
consultative model, on
an hourly billing basis.
This is blowing all
of the out the water,
that at our fingertips we might
have expertise more readily
usable, accessible,
understandable, than ever
before.
And when you think
of the capabilities
of human professionals-- and
we see a lot about this--
we identify four.
It's the cognitive
capabilities, the ability
to think, to solve
problems, to reason,
the manual capabilities,
to work with one's hands.
And you think of vets.
You think of
surgeons or dentists.
You think of the emotional
capabilities, to listen to,
to empathize with one's patients
and clients, and of course
the moral dimension as well.
So what we track
through the book
is to say, well, what
elements of these capability,
looking ahead in a
sane way, do not think
could be taken on by machines?
And so many of the
cognitive tasks, so many
of the manual tasks, and so
many of the emotional tasks,
we think it's
entirely foreseeable
that these tasks
will, in the future,
be undertaken either by
machines autonomously,
or by machines with
less qualified people
than we use today.
The moral dimension I'm going
to turn to at the very end.
But let me put this
in a different way.
What we're seeing
is an evolution
of professional
service, from a model
where the way in which
professional service is
delivered is as some form
craft, the doctor, the lawyer,
the accountant, to a
model where we standardize
in terms of process, checklist,
procedure, manuals, practice
guides.
In terms of substance, you've
got your standard forms,
templates, precedents.
And then we go further,
within our hospitals,
within our firms, within
our schools, we systematize.
And so use automatic
workflow systems
with automatic document
generation systems
and so forth.
And all of this falls
pretty much in the category
of the first sort
of future, where
we're streamlining
and optimizing
the old ways of working.
But what, of course,
is fascinating
in our current era is the
ability to externalize this,
to make this content,
this knowledge,
this practical expertise
available on an online basis.
Now, some organizations,
particularly
professional firms, see a great
commercial opportunity here.
We can make that
expertise available
as a chargeable offering.
Others, particularly
the government
and charitable sector,
will say, actually,
we can make this expertise
and knowledge available online
at no charge.
We'll still control the content,
but we'll make it available.
And the third option, to which
we're very strongly attracted,
is the commons model.
And in the spirit of
Wikipedia, rather than
simply encyclopedic
information, practical expertise
and guidance available in
the open source spirit,
held not by major
organizations or governments,
but actually as a commons
for the use of everyone.
And this, we see, is the
movement that we call,
very crudely, and others use
the same term, commoditization,
a move away from the
craft of the professions
towards online availability
with a charitable,
non-charitable, or available
on a commons basis.
Let me turn to say
a little bit AI,
and then I'll head
to the the '80s,
I wrote my doctorate at
Oxford on AI and law.
And looking back
now, I'm beginning
to make sense of what's
happening in this field.
I was involved in the '80s
in what we called our first--
or we now call our first wave
of artificial intelligence.
And I did my doctorate
from '83 to '86.
Then after for a couple
of years, from '86 to '88,
I worked on the
development of this.
And I want to reassure
you that at the time,
that was quite a
cool screen design.
It looked good.
That was the best.
And actually, the colors matched
well, as with our book today.
But what happened was this.
I just finished
my graduate work .
And the dean of the law
school at Oxford, a man
called Professor
Capron, a partner
at a major
international law firm,
he did a book on a very
complex area of law
called the
[INAUDIBLE] law, which
is a small corner of
the law of limitation.
And he said it's so complicated
no one actually understands it.
Why don't you be
one of my examiners?
He said, why don't we build
a system in this area?
And this was an era when floppy
disks genuinely were floppy.
And this is what the
system looked like,
5.25 floppy disks, two of them.
We wrote a book, and published
it with the two disks
in the back.
But just to give you a flavor
of what we were up against,
section 2 of this act shall
not apply to an action
to which this section applies.
And that was one of the more
readily understandable parts
of the legislation.
So what we were trying
to do was-- surely
we can offer a pathway
through this complex web
of almost unintelligible,
interrelated rules.
And quite frankly, it was a form
of decision tree we developed.
But it was a little
more complicated
than a decision tree because
of the nature of the content
involved.
And typically a question
would look like this.
The content doesn't matter,
but just saying so far it
looks as if the basis of
your claim is negligent,
shall we proceed on this basis?
Yes or no, and navigate through.
Or basically you're offering
other people the opportunity
to navigate through this expert
model of this area of law.
That is a very small
part of the whole system.
It had two million
paths through it.
In a sense, we had to
chart almost every one
of these ourselves.
So this was the
first wave of AI.
What we did was, it was
called knowledge elicitation,
knowledge acquisition.
You sat down with
a human expert.
You mined the [INAUDIBLE]
from their head.
You developed it into
some form of flow chart.
You put it into a system so
other people could use it.
It wasn't just in law.
At the time, there was
a lot of work going on
in rule-based expert systems,
as they were known in medicine.
And I at the time, then
worked for a few years ago
with [INAUDIBLE] and Young.
They were working in tax, and
audit, and consulting as well.
So that was the
model of the '80s,
the expertise taken
from the human brain
and dropped into a box.
Turns out, though, quite costly
to build and maintain systems,
because professional
knowledge changes so rapidly.
Little incentive for the
commercial organizations
to invest.
Remember, most professionals
charge by the hour,
so why would you
want to reduce, as we
were reducing a task
from 2 hours to 2 minutes
if you're charging
by the hour, then
the market's not
wanting that of you.
So there's no
incentive to introduce
this kind of efficiency.
And of course, the
web came along.
And this wasn't doing
the same as the AI
that we were aspiring to,
but it offered, at least
intuitively, an easy way to
make content guidance available
online quickly, cheaply.
And so the AI winter, at
least in the professions,
I attribute to the web.
Because people were
not distracted,
but people were e-tracted.
to a new, easier way of
working with their knowledge.
For us, a turning
point came in the '97.
It's well known that's when
Kasparov, the world chess
champion, was
beaten by Deep Blue.
Now, in the '80s, working
in the computer laboratory,
we used to discuss this a
lot, and we were of the view
that a computer system could
never beat a grandmaster.
Why?
Well, that's because up
until the level of a master,
masters could explain how
they went about playing chess.
When you got to a certain
level, the creative insight,
the bolts out of the blue,
the genius, the experts
themselves, the
grandmasters themselves
couldn't explain
what they were doing.
And this applied right
across the professions.
The great lawyers, the great
doctors, they would also say,
it's intuition.
It's gut reaction.
It's knee-jerk.
We can't explain it.
And we thought, if you can't
explain it, we can't model it.
And therefore, we're limited
to a fairly modest, but quite
useful level of performance
by these systems.
But what we hadn't
banked on, of course,
was exponential increase
in processing power.
And Kasparov was beaten not
by a system that sometimes was
cleverer or more insightful.
It was by brute
force processing,
and, well, the
reality is that it's
a system that could feed up
to a billion possible moves
a second.
And so it is in so
many other professions,
these systems are
outperforming human beings,
not by copying what human beings
do, but by brute force search,
and also by a very
large quantity of data.
Now, Patrick Winston, one of
the fathers of AI research,
put it very well.
There are lots of ways
of being smart that
aren't smart like us.
In the '80s, we thought
the only way of being smart
was being smart like us.
You copied human experts,
knowledge, and performance,
and put into a system.
Why would we do that?
Systems can actually
outperform us
by working in entirely
different ways.
And this leads us
to what we feel
is quite an important insight.
We call this the
AI fallacy, and it
pervades the
academic literature,
the popular literature,
and actually
it's just a common
misconception.
We define it as this, it's
the mistaken assumption
that the only way to develop
systems that perform tasks
at the level of
experts or higher
is to replicate the thinking
process of human specialists.
And so very often,
people say, well,
a system can't perform at
level, because it can't think,
or because we don't know
how human beings operate.
But we think this is fallacious.
Let me give you an example.
Frequently, a lawyer
or a doctor will say,
a computer can't have
judgement like a human being.
Now, that may well
be true, but that's
assuming that that
is the right question
to ask, how can we
somehow replicate
judgement in a machine?
We prefer to take a step back.
We do this a lot in
our book, and ask
the question, to
what the problem
is judgement the solution?
Because the purpose
of these systems
is not simply to streamline.
The current way of
working is find,
using the power of technology,
new ways of solving
the problems.
And when you think
about it, judgement
solves problems of uncertainty.
And when you think about it
also, so much of the technology
that you and others
are involved with
is precisely powerful
ways of dealing
with handling uncertainty,
particularly when large bodies
of data are involved.
And so judgements, the way human
beings cope with uncertainty,
very often we're seeing
across the professions
that technology, and
of course computing,
a very large stores
of data, actually
work in entirely different ways.
There's new ways of
coping with uncertainty.
People often ask,
can machines think?
We love the answer to this
in relation to Watson.
The day after Watson beat the
contestants on the Jeopardy
quiz program, John
Searle, a very well known
American philosopher
said, "Watson
doesn't know it
won in Jeopardy."
And it didn't take people
down to the pub to celebrate.
It didn't reflect on what
we had and hadn't won.
It doesn't think
the same ways we do.
But the key point is,
this non-thinking machine,
it can outperform human beings.
So what we are pointing
to is a category
of increasingly capable
non-thinking machines.
In a sense, we sidestep a lot of
the interesting psychological,
philosophical questions
about AI, but point out,
there's a second
wave of AI that one
can trace to Kasparov, where
we're seeing systems being
developed that
outperform human beings,
but they don't work
like human beings.
And this is the leap
that most people
find hard to make, because
they somehow think,
the identify things that human
beings do that they can't
imagine computers can do,
because they'll say things
like, you can't program
a computer to do XYZ,
failing to understand
that problems can
be cracked in different ways.
And that's the
second wave of AI.
Now, this has profound
implications for employment.
Because what we're seeing is
more and more of the tasks that
are undertaken by
professionals will actually
be undertaken by machines or by
less experienced people working
with machines.
The implications of
that for the job market
is what Daniel's now
going to talk about.
DANIEL SUSSKIND: So I think
this leads to two related
questions being asked.
The first is, will there be any
jobs left for professionals?
And then the second is, now
what can humans do that machines
cannot do?
And I want to look at each
of these questions in turn.
So the first question, will
there be any jobs left?
And the answer to this largely
depends upon time scales.
In the medium term,
we think technology
will lead to a reduction in
traditional professional roles,
but at the same time, we
also think it will give rise
to a whole new set of roles.
So just to pick one,
the knowledge engineers.
This is the sort of thing my
dad was doing in the '80s,
getting the practical expertise
outside of someone's head,
and putting it into a system so
that lay people could use it,
paraprofessionals, less expert,
less specialist people who
use these new systems
and machines to do
the sorts of things
that in the past
would have required an
expert or a specialist.
But the long run's a
very different story,
and that's what I
want to focus on now.
And here, broadly, there
are two schools of thought.
There's the optimists, and
there's the pessimists.
And the pessimists say, no.
There isn't going to be any
work for human professionals
to do in the future.
Machines are becoming
increasingly capable.
They're able to perform more
and more to-do, more and more
types of work.
And so there will be less and
less work for humans to do.
That's the pessimists.
Now, the optimists
say, that's wrong.
Not only is there work today
that only humans can do,
but tomorrow in the future,
we'll create new types of work,
perhaps work that we
can't conceive of today.
And that will be work that
can be done by human beings.
In particular, the
technical criticism
that the optimists make of
the pessimists is they say,
the pessimists are committing
the lump of labor fallacy.
And this is the idea,
the mistaken belief,
that there is some lump of work
in the economy to be divided up
between people and
machines, and machines
doing more of that leaves
less for people to do.
The optimists say,
no, that's it.
As the economy grows and
we become more productive,
we create new types of work.
And people can do that instead.
And it's also here that you see
another line of argument, which
is that optimal future
involves human beings
and machines working
together, each bringing
their own distinctive
capability.
And so the question
is, who is right here?
One of the difficulties in
thinking about this problem
is that when we talk
about the future of work,
we tend to talk about the
different jobs that people do.
So in the professions, we talk
about doctors, and teachers,
and nurses, and lawyers.
But the term "jobs" isn't
entirely illuminating,
because a job isn't a
monolithic, indivisible lump
of work.
Instead, to think about
the future of work,
we have to look at
what people actually
do in their jobs, the type of
tasks that make up their jobs.
Just to give an example, if you
look at nursing, for example,
25 years ago, what a nurse did
was very different from what
a nurse does today.
Then it might have involved
bedpans and bedside
conversation.
Today, nurses can prescribe
certain types of medication
and even perform minor surgery.
The tasks that nurses
do has changed,
but we use the same job
title, nurses, for both.
So why does this matter
about the future of work?
Well, the Economist reviewed
our book two weeks ago.
It was a positive
review, otherwise,
I wouldn't have mentioned it.
And alongside the piece
was this great illustration
of Professor Doctor Robot QC.
And I think there's a sense
in a lot of thinking about
the future of work that one
day, a doctor, or a nurse,
or a teacher is going
to turn up at work
and find Professor Doctor Robot
QC or one of his relatives
sitting in their chair.
Their job would have
been entirely replaced.
and we just don't think
that's how it will play out.
If you imagine a technology
that replaces a task
that a professional
used to do, so here
a less glamorous-looking
remote monitoring system.
This means that people
need to go to the doctor
less for a medical examination.
What we want to say is that the
job that the professional does
has changed.
The doctor, maybe
she'll spend less time
doing medical check-ups, but
she might spend more time
reading the latest research.
And this is why the
term job is unhelpful.
It's too high
level, and it masks
this deeper, underlying
churn in the tasks
that people are doing.
Of course, we can now return to
the optimists and pessimists,
and rephrase it.
The optimists, they
think that there's
going to be enough professional
tasks for human beings
to do in the future, whereas
the pessimists are saying,
no, there's not going to be
enough tasks for human beings
to do in the future.
And the point here
is that, of course,
it's true that if
enough tasks are lost,
it no longer makes sense to
talk of the job under which all
these tasks are bundled.
But we have to start from
the level of the tasks.
So what do we think
now with this thinking
in terms of tasks?
Well, out both the optimists and
pessimists are right and wrong.
The pessimists are right in
recognizing that machines
are becoming increasingly
capable at existing tasks,
but they're wrong
to ignore the fact
that there may be new tasks
to be done in the future.
The optimists are
right to recognize
there will be new tasks that
will done in the future,
but they're wrong to think that
machines rather than people
will be best placed to
perform these tasks.
So our conclusion is
that machines will
become increasingly capable.
They'll take on more and
more of today's tasks.
New tasks will no doubt
emerge, but it's likely
that machines will take
on these tasks as well.
And there is a
serious point here,
which is that we're not
challenging the presumption
that there'll be new work
to be done in the future,
but we are challenging
this idea that necessarily
people rather than machines
will be best placed to do it.
And so we find it hard to avoid
the conclusion that there'll
be a steady decline in the
demand for human professional
in the long run.
The best and the brightest
will last the longest,
either of those who do tasks
that can't be done by machines,
or tasks that ought not
to be done by machines.
And that's something that my
dad will return to in a moment.
But the key point here
is that there just
won't be enough of
these professional tasks
to keep armies of traditional
professionals in employment.
At this point, talking
to professionals,
they say, but surely!
But surely there must be some
tasks that machines can never
do, even in the long run.
And this comes to the second
question that I set up,
are there things that
machines could never do?
When we describe this
situation, we tend to say
or we say that
professionals have
a Rubik's Cube conception of
what machines are capable of.
So here is an
expression of a man
who builds a machine out
of LEGO and a smartphone
that can solve a Rubik's
Cube in 3.4 seconds.
You pop the Rubik's Cube in
there, press go, it sinks in,
pops up, it's solved.
And I think most professional
see this and say, yeah,
this is clearly a manually
dexterous and complicated task,
but of course
machines can do it.
It's rule based.
It's clearly defined.
It's logical.
It's a routine task.
And professionals then said,
but what we do is non-routine.
We rely on creativity.
We rely on judgement.
We rely on empathy.
All of these are
non-routine things,
and surely machines can
never do non-routine tasks.
And this is also a distinction,
the non-routine routine one,
that runs through lots and
lots of academic writing
on the future of work.
And we say not so fast.
Two mistakes are
being made here.
And the first is this
idea of decomposition
that my dad spoke about.
To start with, when you
take professional work
and break it down into
its component parts,
it turns out that
many of those parts
are routine rather
than non-routine.
Actually, not much
that a professional
does, in cases not much at all,
relies upon empathy, judgement,
creativity in a way
that is often said.
But the second point comes
back to the AI fantasy,
which is that even those
non-routine tasks that exist
can often be done in
different ways by machines.
The mistake is to think
that because a machine can't
think it can never be created.
Because a machine can't
feel, it can't be empathetic.
What we often notice
here, and what we find
is that these machines operate
often in very inhuman ways,
but they can take on
these tasks as well.
So this line of thinking on
professional tasks prompts
a more fundamental
question, and that's--
RICHARD SUSSKIND: You're done.
DANIEL SUSSKIND: Yeah.
RICHARD SUSSKIND: Thank you.
As Daniel said at the
outset, we thought
we were writing a book about
the future of the professions,
but it turned out we
were really writing
a book about the
future of expertise,
how you capture and share
expertise in society.
And the question that we
therefore ask and then answer
in the book is precisely
that in more formal terms,
the production and distribution
of practical expertise
in society.
So how do we produce
and distribute
practical expertise in society?
The current answer,
the traditional model,
is the professions.
And I know it's been that
way since the outset.
That's the way that we found
best both to generate and make
available expertise.
We put particular
occupational groups in charge,
we give them exclusive rights,
and they get on with it.
And we've identified
problems [INAUDIBLE] with it.
But what we've also
identified in our book
were six alternative models.
And there's no time today to
delve into each, but in a sense
this is at the
heart of the book,
because not only are we
saying there's problems
with the current model.
We're actually saying there's
some viable alternatives
out there.
And we've touched
on a few of them,
for example, the knowledge
engineering model.
Rather than having
a human expert
dispense the advice on a
one-to-one consultative
advisory basis, that
human expert's knowledge
and experience is
modded into the system
and made available on
a one-to-many basis.
That's the knowledge
in [INAUDIBLE].
Pretty much, actually,
according with the first wave
of AI in the '80s.
Then there's the communities of
experience model, for example.
We touched on this.
This is gonna be
terribly significant.
Where recipients of professional
advice, patients, clients,
actually come
together and say, this
is how I sorted out the problem.
This is what I was
advised, or this is
how I sorted it out personally.
And I will make that
available to others.
And we'll see this community.
We think it may well need to
be moderated by specialist
individuals, but
we'll see communities
of professional experience
build up, which may well
be the first port of
call for many individuals
when they need
guidance on anything.
The most extreme
version of which
are book has been
allied with exclusively
is the machine-generated model.
That's the idea that
there might be autonomous
machines that are actually both
generating and distributing
practical expertise.
We can see decades from
now that in many areas
of the professions,
this will be the case.
But what we don't want to leave
anyone with the impression with
is that it's either the case
of autonomous robots dispensing
advice, or the
traditional model.
There are a variety of
models in the world.
I want to close with
the issue of morality.
Because it seemed to us--
and we addressed them
both in the book-- there are
two big moral issues that
arise from the subjects
we are addressing.
And the first in chapter 7,
or actually the conclusion,
we asked the question,
what future should we want?
The first question we asked
was this, what tasks ought not
be handled by machines?
So even if machines,
in one way or another,
machines work with less
well qualified people,
can match the
cognitive, the manual,
the effective capabilities,
of a human professionals,
might there not be some
areas of human life
we simply don't want to
hand over to machines?
Do we want machines to be making
decisions about the turning off
of life support systems?
Do we want machines to be
passing life sentences?
Do we really want the moral buck
to be stopping at the robot?
And most of us feel-- it may
be irrational-- but most of us
feel, I think, an
intuitive unease
when we think about this.
And we actually think this
is a huge issue, which
probably extends well
beyond the professions.
And we liken it to
the issue of IVF
as it was discussed in
the early '80s, where
a very famous
philosopher, Mary Warnock,
was invited to do an inquiry
into the moral implications
of this American technology.
So in our book, we
called for a similar kind
of public government-led
discussion, debate,
about the limits of the use
of this kind of technology
in employment.
And of course, the professions
were a special example, but so
many pressing moral issues
arising within the professions.
Now is the time to start
debating whether or not
we think it's appropriate
that these tasks, or some
of these tasks, are
taken on by machines.
And the second question
now weighs even bigger.
We're seeing that this practical
expertise, the knowledge,
experience, insight,
know-how of human experts
can actually be captured and
made available in new ways.
So the question is, if human
beings through their labor
and often in the
service, and this
is captured and
available largely online,
who should own and control
tomorrow's practical expertise?
Now, we say in the
book, we're actually
coming to a fork in the road.
We're not quite there
yet, but there's two very
different paths.
One is where you see big
business, government,
withholding the control
and therefore dispensing.
It's a new form of bargain.
It's a new grand bargain,
a new exclusivity,
dispensing this
practical expertise.
And the other, and it
might sound fanciful,
but it's more of a commons
that insofar as possible,
and if we can provide the
incentives to encourage people
to contribute to this,
we see a road ahead
where practical expertise is
available at no or at low cost
right across the
global community,
derived from the
best human experts,
but actually delivered
in a more effective way.
Now, are money is on
that second option,
but that's something that
we want to discuss with you.
Thank you for listening.
[APPLAUSE]
MALE SPEAKER: Thank
you very much.
For this very interesting talk.
Who has questions?
That is the most hands I've
ever seen for questions.
AUDIENCE: So just
to start off, when
you saying is the first place.
I was very struck that you
didn't mention the competence
aspect, which I imagine
most professions would
say was their bar
of entry, and that's
what they're guaranteeing in
exchange for the exclusivity.
DANIEL SUSSKIND: What you see
is in practice [INAUDIBLE]
medicine for example,
diagnosis is a bit [INAUDIBLE].
We were on a panel the
other day with a doctor
making exactly that defense.
He said the most important thing
that I do is diagnose patients.
And that is something
that I do very well.
In fact, if you look at the
data, up to 20% of the time,
doctors make mistakes
with diagnoses.
And what you then see,
outside of the professions,
are machines operating
in very different ways,
diagnosing in very
different ways that
have for certain types
of cancer or reviewing
certain types of
scans and radiography,
and here is the view that they
can outperform human beings.
So it's important
not to set a bar
for those outside
the professions that
doesn't match the one the
professions currently achieve.
Generally, the
standard, the instinct
is to say-- there's
another example.
There's an autonomous
robot in San Francisco
that delivers prescriptions.
And it has delivered 6
million prescriptions,
and it's made one error so far.
They said it's due
to human error.
And a lot of people say,
that's not acceptable.
It shouldn't be making an error.
At best, human pharmacists
make an error 1% of a time.
6 million prescriptions,
1% of the time, that's
60,000 mistakes, not one.
So the short answer is
outside of the professions,
there appear to be lots
of systems and machines
operating in very
different ways that
challenge this idea that
professions are necessarily
the only way to provide
high quality expertise.
RICHARD SUSSKIND: But you are
right that that's the argument
the professionals will use.
It's part of what we
call the grand bargain.
The question you ask is, why
do we give exclusive rights?
[RINGTONE]
Well, this is
tremendously important.
Your health is
Your legal welfare,
this is vital stuff.
You don't want any Joe
conducting brain surgery,
just as you don't want any
joe in the High court standing
up and representing you.
And therefore, we should
have the exclusive rights
over certain areas
of human activity,
because what we can
just about guarantee
is that we'll deliver a
higher quality than anyone
else who hasn't got our
training or ongoing educations.
As Daniel says, I think
our book basically
is challenging the
grand bargain, saying
that grand bargain made sense
in a brick-based industrial
society from the
19th century onwards,
but actually, once you start
decomposing and looking
at much of the work
that's done, as Dan says,
there are different
ways, systems, processes,
people who can deliver as
high a quality of service
without the exclusivity
which probably
bring the mystification, the
greater cost, the greater
complexity, and the alienation
that many of them suffer.
DANIEL SUSSKIND: Just to
add one thing to that,
the example we talked
about at the start,
with eBay and the 60
millions disputes that
are resolved online,
in the absence
of that e-mediation platform,
those 60 million disputes
would have probably
gone unresolved.
That is 40 times as many
of a similar type of claim
that result in the
English justice system.
So it may be the case that
this e-mediation platform,
on a case by case
basis, provides--
unless you get the best
judge in the country
to adjudicate each
dispute on eBay,
it may be the case
that that judge
would reach a better decision.
We're talking about
60 million people
who probably wouldn't
have received
a resolution without it.
It would have been
a resolution they
weren't happy with otherwise.
There's a quotation
from Voltaire,
"you shouldn't let the best
be the enemy of the good."
Lots of these systems offer good
alternatives not to the best,
but to nothing, which
people currently have.
And this is a story that you
see across the professions.
What are the professions for?
They're responsible for some
of the most important things
that we do in society.
And for the reasons I've said,
in lots of different ways,
they're failing.
And these systems, in
case, can offer better,
but in some cases,
they just offer good,
and good is better than nothing.
And even now that's
true. [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
The next question is, have
you considered something
about how you handle outliers?
So you have the case like
for the airline pilot, where
most of the time,
the autopilot does
a great job of flying the
plane, and probably better
than the real pilot.
But then you get into
an emergency situation
where he has to
choose whether to land
on the river, or the golf
course, or the highway.
Doing the routine work makes
the airline pilot better
in an emergency.
And so by segmenting the
work, you lose that extreme.
So I guess in this
situation, if the best
is the enemy of the good,
who decides when actually
the best is important enough
that we don't go with automated
planes or whatever else.
RICHARD SUSSKIND: There's
actually a few questions there.
One is, how do you
become an expert?
It's the old training ground.
You used to cut your teeth
in more routine work,
so we've got a whole
section discussing that.
The other question,
actually, funnily enough
is something I can
[INAUDIBLE] never
really answered in the '80s.
Because my view, when
I was working on expert
systems was that
these systems were
very good at solving
what I called
clear cases of
the expert domain.
By that I meant problems
that were easy for experts,
but not too easy
for non-experts.
But these systems weren't
very good for sorting out
problems for expects.
They'd say, actually,
that's quite tricky.
But the difficulty is that
if you're not an expert,
you don't know if a problem
is easy or hard, even
for an expert.
So there's a border
mindset of gray.
Sometimes, it's
perfectly obvious
that something's
very complicated,
but sometimes also
there's a gray area,
where you might
default to what looks
like a rather simple solution,
but actually miss a nuance.
And our inclination
is, actually--
to Dan's point again, the
best is the enemy of the good,
in many areas of
professional work, which
aren't threats of life of
death, we probably just
need to accept that
what we're now getting
is 19 times out of 10
rather than 0 out of 0.
Sorry, 19 times out of 20,
The great insight you've made
there is where there really
are terribly high
risks that follow,
we really will need
experts involved
doing the triage
in the first place,
seeing whether or
not this is something
that can actually be
disposed of by a machine
or by an individual.
Going back to the
earlier question
of how you become
an expert, it's
fascinating, because
it's a training question.
How do we train people?
And I'll give you
example in law.
In law, it could be an
indictment, I think,
of major law firms, but
the way you want to learn
is during one's traineeship,
for example, to be a litigator,
is you're often
assigned to a basement
room with a huge
body of documents,
either electronically
or in folders.
And it's called document review.
You have to review
these documents.
And you do that looking
for relevant ones.
And I did a little
bit of research,
went asking some junior
lawyers and said,
if this was automated--
and there's now
technology that could outperform
junior lawyers-- would
this mean that you're losing
a major learning opportunity?
And the response was,
look, we get how to do this
after two or three days.
We don't need to do it
for two or three years.
[LAUGHTER]
I rather cynically say,
don't confuse training
with exploitation.
The training of
many professionals
is a little bit of a deal.
You go in there to
a high branded firm.
The market's still happy to pay
fairly high rates for people
who are fairly junior.
And the way the market
is, the clients just
say, actually, we're just paying
for these young professionals
to do our work.
And until 2005, 2006, there
wasn't even much wrong
with that, because there was
more money swilling around.
But now you're even seeing in
accounting, consulting, tax,
law, audit, [INAUDIBLE] clients
say we no longer want to pay.
So it's actually a
fascinating challenge
to the business model.
Because, actually, what it means
is that many professional firms
are actually going
to have to invest
in very practical training
rather than hoping
it can be picked up on the job.
My answer in the longer run
is-- and one would expect this,
and I hope it resonates-- is
that-- it's part of our book
as well, [INAUDIBLE] education.
There are far more
powerful ways, I think,
of exposing people
to a far wider range
of professional
problems and situations
using simulated learning
environments rather than
natural learning environments.
And we're shown this
[INAUDIBLE] university
training young lawyers.
We've created a virtual
town called [INAUDIBLE]
in which young, aspiring
lawyers practice law for a year.
And actually we have simulated
the actual negotiations,
the actual court
appearances, the interactions
with the clients in
a way the, frankly,
slightly random exposure
to the experience
you get in the world of training
with a firm doesn't really
provide.
My major point is,
most clients say
when they ask you questions,
they actually say,
that's your problem.
It's a training problem
you've got to sort it out.
But if we can find a way of
sorting our problems that's
cheaper, quicker,
more effective,
we want you to
provide [INAUDIBLE].
But you raise a major challenge.
So these are quite long answers,
but they're complex questions.
AUDIENCE: So I want to get
your thought about letting
a machine, say, run a country.
RICHARD SUSSKIND: I
think that raises really
the first moral question.
Do we think that-- I'll start
with the moral question.
Are we comfortable
with the notion
that decisions and issues
of policy, people's welfare,
and economy, and justice,
and health, and so
forth are handed
over to machines
from a moral point of view?
And I'm not making
an observation there.
I think we need to have a public
debate about whether or not
our intuitions about this
actually are well founded.
But I think most people
would draw the line there.
We'd say we don't really
want a robot at the helm.
But I could see a whole
bundle of other arguments
that would say,
well, actually you
could say a machine might
have far better data
at its fingertips, be able to
make more rational decisions.
I think, on balance,
I would default
to suggesting that
what we will do
is have responsible human
beings making moral decisions
but increasingly supported
by these powerful systems.
We had a fascinating
discussion here in the book--
it's not quite your
question, but it's
an extreme example-- with a
very senior military individual.
Because we're thinking the
profession of being of soldier,
we thought we might cover,
but we didn't in the end.
And with a lot of reflection
in this context of machines
conducting warfare and so forth.
These are tricky issues.
They become trickiest
where the machines wildly
outperform human beings in tasks
which are very important to us
from a moral decision
point of view.
Because the intuition that
a human being must involved
may well be trumped by this
massive leap in performance
by a machine.
I heard your question as a
little bit of a provocation.
It doesn't really need to be one
observation though-- we don't
see the professions-- and
if you consider politics
to be a profession--
we don't see this
to be an overnight revolution.
Daniel's point about
Professor Doctor Robot
you see sitting at
the desk one day,
it's not that that
appears one day.
It's not a tipping point.
It's not a revolution.
But nor is it a
leisurely evolution.
We view it as an
incremental transformation.
So what we think we'll
see in the professions,
and I suppose in
politics too is,
you'll see step
changes over the years.
And you'll look
back, say, 30 years,
and say, wow, it
is unrecognizable.
But it's not like in
some areas of life
where there genuinely is
a fundamental stopping
of an old era and a
starting of a new era.
So I think what we'll
find in politics, possibly
a more evolutionary role
than a transformational role.
It's steady, rapid change.
Did you want to [INAUDIBLE].
DANIEL SUSSKIND: It's also the
case that those big questions
are fascinating,
interesting, important,
but there is, just,
again, to come back
to the spirit of the
conversation we were having
before, in the day-to-day,
many of the systems
and machines that exist,
they can't run a country,
but they can do a good job at
the things that lots of people
don't have access to.
So we shouldn't be blinded or
scared by those big questions.
And to thinking about today,
and the next months and years,
how can we use these
increasingly capable systems
and machines to just do a
better job for more people who
currently don't have
access to a professional.
RICHARD SUSSKIND: If you
think of the division
of the legislature, executive,
and judiciary of government,
I'm involved.
I was actually advisor to
the [INAUDIBLE] justice.
Since '98, I've been
advising the computerization
of the court system.
This is a glacial business.
It moves very, very slowly.
Dan's absolutely right.
Your question's fascinating,
but actually, there's
a lot we can do, for example,
in our justice system,
how we run our courts with
the kind of technologies
that frankly many of you
absolutely take for granted.
They would greatly improve
access to justice today.
And so investment's probably
not so much in the replacement
of the cabinet.
It's more--
DANIEL SUSSKIND:
Getting rid of the fax
machines in the court system.
RICHARD SUSSKIND: That's right.
It's the machinery
of government.
It could at least be
streamlined considerably.
MALE SPEAKER: I think there
are many more questions,
but unfortunately, we
have run out of time.
MALE SPEAKER: I
think you're gonna
stay around for [INAUDIBLE].
RICHARD SUSSKIND: I can stay
around, [INAUDIBLE] yes.
FEMALE SPEAKER: I've just
been waiting for a long time.
Can you take one more?
[LAUGHTER]
DANIEL SUSSKIND:
I'll take one more.
MALE SPEAKER: Can we
take one more question?
MALE SPEAKER: With
a very quick answer.
[INAUDIBLE]
DANIEL SUSSKIND: Finish
with a big one, then.
FEMALE SPEAKER: I
was thinking that-- I
don't want to be
insulting, but when
you think about the adjectives
that you picked, for example,
when you say that we don't
need any professionals,
you see that as a
pessimistic point of view,
but when you look at-- let's say
you're not in the UK anymore,
and let's look from the view of
all the countries in the world.
For example, in
the Ebola outbreak
in Africa, people
really needed doctors,
but they didn't have doctors.
And they really needed
nurses, and they didn't really
have nurses.
And some of the failed states,
the reason that they are still
failed states is not only
because of terrorism,
or military issues, but they
don't have enough professions.
For example, I, myself,
at my private school,
we were 75 kids for one teacher.
Can you imagine it?
And so it was really hard.
So what I was saying is I think
it's an optimistic future when
we don't need professions.
RICHARD SUSSKIND: I hope we
didn't come across negatively.
When Daniel was talking about
pessimists and optimists,
that was very much from the
professionals' point of view.
DANIEL SUSSKIND: Professionals
saying that's a pessimistic--
RICHARD SUSSKIND: No,
you're absolutely right.
Just a tiny little riff,
you know the language.
I'm sure it's been used a lot
within Google about disruption.
We, although we're big fans
of Clayton Christiansen's book
on "The Innovator's Dilemma"
and his work in disruption,
we expressly say we're
not using that term.
Because to say that
medicine, and law,
and so forth are being
disrupted actually
is a very provider-supplier
point of view.
From the point of view of
the recipient of the service,
this might mean greater,
cheaper, better access
to medicine and health.
So we think the word disruption
carries with it phrases
which are slightly contentious.
You are absolutely right
in your observation.
What you say,
though, when you say
the reason these
states have failed
is because they don't
have professions,
you see, we would put
it rather differently.
We'd say the reasons
the states have failed
is because they don't have
solutions to the which
the professions are thought
historically to be the answer.
And what we're saying
is, actually, they
need not be the answer.
So what I'm working,
for example,
I've done a little bit of work
with third world countries
on new justice systems.
I say, don't replicate ours.
You can leapfrog.
You don't need to go through
the process we've gone through,
what ends up being rather
antiquated and not totally fit
for [INAUDIBLE].
You can jump to, for example,
online dispute resolution.
That's a great
question to finish on.
Thanks very much, everyone.
DANIEL SUSSKIND:
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]